[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRENT SHAFFER: Come,
everybody, gather round.
I'm going to tell you a
wonderful, magical tale,
a tale of two Google employees
who set off on a bold journey
to create an entirely serverless
application on Google Cloud.
Some of these events
might frighten you,
but you're going to learn
a lot about Google Cloud
and maybe even a little
bit about yourself.
So first the dream.
So if you've been
around this area,
you'll see a lot of
these experiments.
What you may not know
is these experiments
are also available online.
And you can go to
showcase.withgoogle.com,
and you can launch these
apps and mess with them
in your own browser.
You can also browse the
code and download it
and launch it yourself.
My friend Sandeep, who
you may see him around.
He's also a Cloud Googler.
Him and I had an idea to make
this app, a montage maker.
And what a montage
maker is is it
something that will
create a video that's
assembled from clips of
words from another video that
have been reordered to say
or show something different.
So for instance, if you
uploaded a political speech,
then you could
make, potentially,
by rearranging the words
said in that video,
you could make the politician
sing the Pokemon theme song,
for example.
So let's see what
this looks like.
We decided to take
a couple of videos
from DevRelers from Cloud
Next 2018 and have them sing--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Never going--
BRENT SHAFFER: Rick Astley.
- --to give you up.
Never going to let you down.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENT SHAFFER: OK.
Let me do that one more time.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Never going to give you up.
Never going to let you down.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENT SHAFFER: So not
exactly a deep fake,
but you get the idea.
So what this consists
of is a back end
which will take a video
and it will separate it
into individual word
clips for each word
and a front end that
will take a text input
and it will assemble
that text into videos
using the clips that we
split from the back end.
Now, what makes this serverless?
Well, nothing makes
this serverless
except how we decided
to architect it.
So we wanted to keep scalability
in mind at the forefront
so that it can scale
up automatically
and it scales down to 0
when we're not using it.
We also wanted it
to be event based.
So nothing is running until
it's spun up by something.
And we wanted to have our code
broken apart into microservices
and also have
minimal data at rest.
So let's go to a demo.
Hi, Google Cloud Next.
I really hope this demo works.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, Google Cloud Next.
I really hope this demo works.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENT SHAFFER: OK.
Good enough.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so let's talk
about how we built it.
The front end is
pretty straightforward.
Not really all that
much serverless
going on here anyway.
We have a front end being served
by Firebase hosting, which
is a really easy way to
deploy a simple HTML app.
And in JavaScript, we call a
back end basically functioning
as an API, which is a Cloud
Function listening on a HTTP
trigger.
And that Cloud Function
takes a text string
and looks and sees if those
clips exist in cloud storage.
And if they do,
it combines them.
And if it doesn't, it
fills in the missing words
with the Text-to-Speech
API, which
is what you saw with
the Cloud Platform logo
in the previous demo.
So a back end that
isn't serverless
might look something like this.
And this is your
code sitting on, say,
Compute Engine, a VM, whatever.
You give it a video.
It uses video
intelligence API, which
can give you the start and end
times for every word and using
that information, cut up
the video into word clips.
But since we want to go
serverless, for starters,
we decided that we use a cloud
storage bucket to initialize
the Cloud Function.
So when you drop a video
into a bucket and it
spins up our Cloud Function.
But we can do one better,
because the video API, Video
Intelligence API, can save the
results of the start and end
time of every word into
JSON file in cloud storage.
So now we can make
that asynchronous.
We're not waiting on our
Video Intelligence API
to process our video anymore.
We just sent off
the API request.
That function dies.
And then once the
Video Intelligence API
is finished processing,
a new called function
is triggered, which then
splits the word into clips.
So now we have three
storage buckets
on the back end, one storage
bucket on the front end.
And at this point
if you're going,
I thought this was supposed
to be a happy ending story,
you're not alone.
So this is pretty complicated.
If anyone told you that
Cloud Functions is something
that you just run your
code and you walk away
and you don't have to worry
about servers or anything else
anymore, then they lied.
But before we get
too discouraged,
let me show you what it
looks like, because everybody
loves a good demo.
So here are our cloud
storage buckets.
I have a video
here from my good--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Felipe Hoffa.
You're interested
in visualizing data.
Prepare to rewind.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENT SHAFFER: My good
friend Felipe Hoffa,
who is also a Googler.
So if we architected
this correctly,
this will have fired
off a Cloud Function.
We can verify this by going
into our logs viewer here.
And it'll take a
couple of seconds.
But if everything goes well--
there we go.
This is the logs
for our functions.
And if you're unfamiliar
with Cloud Functions,
you can break down all of their
logs right here in Stackdriver
to see what they're
doing at any given time.
So what should have happened is
this fired off an API request
to the Video Intelligence API.
And I am intentionally
stalling, because I'm
hoping when I go into Montage
Annotations-- yep, sweet.
JSON's already there.
So this is the transcription
data for our video.
And you can see has the correct,
mostly correct sentence here.
Start and end times.
And I'm stalling again,
because I'm hoping
by the time I go into here--
yep.
We have all of our videos.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Rewind.
Interested.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENT SHAFFER: OK, awesome.
So just to recap, we use
Cloud Function functions
for all the glue code.
We use Cloud Storage
for storing our data
and also for triggering
additional functions.
We use the Video Intelligence
API for identifying words
in the video.
We use the Test-to-Speech API
for filling in missing words.
And Pub/Sub maybe?
Other technologies
used, just for fun.
We use Firebase
Hosting for serving
HTML, NodeJS for
the function code,
FFmpeg for any audio or video
manipulation nerds out there.
We used Firebase CLI to actually
deploy the functions, which
it's a really nice interface.
It's a really great
way to get started.
We use Cloud Source Repositories
for version control and Cloud
Shell Editor and Cloud
Shell for editing the code,
running the tests,
and deploying.
So we are fully integrated
into the cloud with this one.
So let's talk about the bugs.
Then the bugs came.
So the first issue we ran into
was the Video Intelligence API
is just--
it's really not that precise.
So the precision is
1/10 of a second, which
if you're talking as
quickly as I am now
or as most people
speak in conversation,
that's not enough to really
get an isolated word.
So to get around that, we
did a couple of things.
We added a second buffer and
used the fade in and fade out,
which did help.
But at the end of
the day, we just
had to approve each word,
which is a horrible process,
but it's still better than
going through and clipping
these words out yourself.
And we did this
with an admin UI.
I'll show this real
quickly, just for fun.
Probably one in every
five words is good.
That's how--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Kubernetes.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENT SHAFFER:
Unprecise this is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Landscape.
Laptop.
The launch.
[END PLAYBACK]
BRENT SHAFFER: So the
longer words are better.
Shorter words like the and this
and a, the real common ones
are really difficult to get.
Now, these are the
more fun issues.
So we started by uploading
these five minute videos.
They got chopped
up about as quickly
as you saw the demo here.
And we thought, this is great.
We architected this
thing to scale.
We're feeling really
good about ourselves.
Then we tried a 60 minute video.
And can anybody guess
what went wrong?
You saw the
architectural diagram.
We didn't guess either.
But this actually
seems really obvious.
So the first thing
that happened is
we hit maximum execution time.
Cloud Function can only
run for nine minutes,
and we're having it chop up
60 minutes worth of words.
So you remember, we have
a Cloud Function fire
off once the annotations
land in Cloud Storage.
How do we fix it?
I foreshadowed it.
Pub/Sub.
Yes, Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is the hero we needed.
Pub/Sub is built
for scalability.
It's highly available.
It's global.
It's awesome.
So we stuck it right here.
We had every single
function, every single word
spin up a Pub/Sub message to
be handled by another function.
We added an additional Cloud
Function specifically just
to clip the words up.
So you're seeing
microservices in play.
We're cutting this application
up into the tiniest of pieces.
Can anyone tell me what
went wrong with this?
Maximum number of
parallel functions.
So a 60 minute video
of someone talking
has 10,000 words maybe,
something around there.
6,000 words.
All being processed
at the same time
with a function
for each of them.
So here we got a little greedy.
We went too far down
the distribution path.
And as a result of having
too many functions,
we then had too many outstanding
Pub/Sub messages as well,
and then what happens
if you have too many
outstanding Pub/Sub messages?
They get dropped.
So we were just having
words that were lost.
This had a pretty easy solution.
We just added batching.
So instead of having every
single function process one
word, we had every function
spin up and process 10 words.
We probably could've gone as
far as a couple hundred words,
because we initially
only had one function,
and it was processing
five minutes of video.
So this is another one
of those trade offs
where it will get done faster
the more of these Cloud
Functions you spin up.
But then you could hit
some of these limits.
So we immediately
hit the CPU quota
exceeded, because let's
say we had 10,000 words.
Now we're spinning up close
to 1,000 functions a second.
And each of them are
processing 10 words,
which probably takes a minute.
So we're hitting this CPU quota.
Now, we could get around this
by pausing after so many words,
only processing
so many at a time.
What we did was
we just requested
that our quota got raised,
because a lot of these quotas
are configurable.
And that worked.
So that was nice.
And I'm really glad we
got this error next,
because it meant that we got the
grand slam of Cloud Functions
errors.
We hit maximum execution time,
maximum number of threads,
maximum CPU, and maximum memory.
So I guess we're
doing something right.
Now, a Cloud
Function can only be
configured for two
gigabytes of memory,
and that is a hard limit.
So when we hit this, we knew
we had to fix something.
Luckily, it was a
bug in our code.
We had to configure
FFmpeg to use streams
so it wasn't operating on
an entire 60 minute video.
And there was another
issue that we had here
where we were storing the 60
minute video in a temp file
and not cleaning it up.
And that's an issue
that I'm going
to talk about in a second.
So some Cloud
Functions operations,
optimizations out
there that you really
do need to keep in mind whenever
you're using Cloud Functions,
is each function spins
up an instance specific
to its function.
So you have a Function A
and Function B. Function
A is going to spin
up a Function A
instance that can handle
multiple Function A
invocations.
So in our case, when we
had these functions that
were processing a 60
minute video, each of them
were pulling down a 60 minute
video file, storing it in temp,
and in Cloud Functions
the file system is memory.
So you're filling up your
two gigabytes of memory.
And we weren't cleaning
it up, and those files
stuck around until the function
ran on memory and crashed.
What we did, we can actually
use that to our advantage
and have every function check
and see if the video was
already downloaded.
And now you skip
having to download
that video for each function.
So you can use the temp
directory and the globals
in Cloud Functions
as a caching system.
Another optimization
is function size.
So if you use Firebase
CLI, it's really easy
because it just takes
an app, a singular app,
and it deploys it to
every single function.
And this is really
great to get started,
but once your
application matures,
you're going to want
to split each function
to its own application
so that you don't
have a function deploying
with another function's
dependencies.
So in our case, our
annotate video function,
which all it does is call
the Video Intelligence API,
it was loading in 300
megabytes of dependencies
that were being used in some of
the more complex functions that
use FFmpeg.
So keep that in mind.
If you use Firebase CLI, this is
an optimization you might want.
In the G Cloud, you can
also deploy functions
with the G Cloud CLI.
That's one of the
advantages it has.
It's a little bit
harder to use, but it
does give you the ability to
deploy individual code bases.
So denouement.
Let's resolve this story.
Our takeaway was building
scalable serverless apps is--
it wasn't terrible.
It wasn't great.
It's just a very
different paradigm
and one we weren't used to.
So be prepared for that.
You have different challenges.
You're going to run into
some big frustrations.
I'm going to go
through the cons first,
because I want to
end on a high note.
First one we already
talked about.
Seemingly simple apps
get very complex.
If we weren't serverless,
this is a pretty good solution
for what we wanted
on our back end.
And it might actually
work just as well.
And this is what
we came up with.
This is actually the flow.
And this looks insane.
If someone was like,
hey, here's our app,
you're gonna have to debug
this, and they hand me
a piece of paper that looked
like that, I would be like,
you guys, you messed this up.
This isn't right.
As a result, debugging
is really hard.
So you can watch the logs
for function invocations,
but at the end of
the day, there's
no way to see an event go
from start to finish easily.
And I know we have
products like Cloud Trace
and we might be able to
integrate that in there.
Didn't have time to try that.
So it may be possible
in the future,
but currently there's
nothing out of the box that
allows you to do this.
So you're stuck looking at
logs and refreshing storage
buckets, which is not--
it's a little more
difficult to follow.
And another thing is serverless
abstracts away your code
from the hardware,
and that's true.
So you don't have to worry
about hardware limitations,
but instead you have
quota limitations, which
can be just as frustrating.
So let's talk about some
good things, though.
The app forced us to
think about microservices.
And as a result, you
get a lot of good things
with microservices.
For instance, the fact that
each function is hermetic.
Deploying a new one
is quick, and it
won't affect any of the other
running components of your app.
Also quote exceptions
were indicators of flaws
in our design every time.
With the exception of the
CPU quota that we had raised,
we were able to get around the
quotas by better architecture
of our app.
And it forced us to think
about things that we hadn't
previously thought about.
Quota increases
also, in general,
are better than adding
hardware, especially
if you haven't architected
your application
to scale with new hardware.
You just build it on a single
Compute Engine instance,
you can add another
Compute Engine instance
and it's not going
to help you at all.
Also, there was very little
code required in our apps.
This entire application had
under 300 lines of JavaScript,
and that was when I just looked
backstage before this talk.
I didn't remove white space
or comments or logging
or any of that stuff.
So it's relatively
small, easy to maintain.
Another really good aspect
to this is the cost.
So we talked about
scaling down to 0.
We left the app inactive
for several weeks,
and the total cost was 0.1
dollar a day, one cent a day.
Best cent a day I
ever spent on tech.
And this was just
to house the videos
that we had in cloud storage.
Our most expensive day
during development,
this was when we were throwing
all sorts of videos at it
and we were blowing
through quotas
and we had tons
of inefficiencies
and things that were
costing us extra money
was still only $100.
And the total cost for the
project over two months
was about $200.
So if you were running all
of this on a Compute Engine
instance and you really
feel that you made it really
beefy so that it could hold
all this, it would be about $50
a month.
So it'd be pretty cheap.
But whenever you're
not using it,
you're still paying
that same price.
So it's going to catch up.
So was it worth the
trouble of serverless?
I don't know.
I guess that's for
you guys to decide.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]